[Applause]
[Music]
we can't stop won't stop
hi
[Music]
[Applause]
please welcome my very good friend mr.
Todd Howard
[Applause]
[Music]
they delivered big-time
well thank you Tim you can start the
show
my name is Pete Hines and I'm delighted
to be back onstage for Bethesda's fourth
annual III showcase now we're starting
with a game that we announced a few
weeks ago through our friends at Walmart
Canada
perhaps best known for their low prices
and ability to keep a secret
I'm thrilled to announce that we will
soon be relaunching the elderscrolls
legends with brand new totally
overhauled visuals I'm also very excited
to let you all know that legends will be
available later this year on Nintendo
switch Xbox one and PlayStation 4
content comes out so regularly for Elder
Scrolls online we're already working on
our great plans for next year but before
that the next DLC coming out is a
dungeon dlc named wolf hunter base on
werewolves and later this year we have a
story DLC named Merc mire we're going
back to Black Marsh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and thank you thanks so much
I'm Marty Stratton executive producer of
doom eternal you want to see hell on
earth well we we just teased it I'm
Joshua Boyle community manager for quake
champions check out our new trailer for
quake Sam
[Applause]
the next time you fire at prey you're
gonna see three new modes story mode new
game+ which was a big fan request and
survival mode which should be an
interesting challenge for our most
hardcore fans but that's just the
beginning
we're so excited we can't wait till once
[Music]
before we begin yes mom I'm still alive
no I'm not a mimic hang on there no last
year millions of you took to the streets
and sparked a revolution in Wolfenstein
to the new Colossus as BJ blaskowitz you
rallied the American resistance and you
beat the living [ __ ] out of those Nazis
Wolfenstein revolution continues with
our next project which leaps ahead in
time to tell the tale of BJ's twin
daughters set in the 1980s in Paris
Wolfenstein Youngblood pushes the story
forward it's not about the pain you can
do
[Music]
it's about how much you can take
[Music]
it's do-or-die sis just like Papa taught
us will you please welcome my very good
friend mr. Todd Howard but we know that
most of you came here for one thing
thank you I think it's to see where
we're putting Skyrim next Alexa play
Skyrim you're a level 57 and see a tall
snowy mountain
climate now Skyrim and life become one a
mud crabs cuddles tore this lid off I
didn't catch that race I didn't quite
catch
so it's all the way to so Vanguard what
happened
FUS ro dah that's the command for
knocking things over is there a command
for picking [ __ ] up every which that
level yet fallout 76 is a prequel to all
the other games and it's our biggest one
yet it is four times the size of fallout
4 because yes
fallout 76 is entirely online of course
you can play this solo alright you'll
you'll be who you want exploring a huge
world doing quests experiencing a story
and leveling up as you venture out into
this new American frontier some of your
fellow survivors may not be neighborly
we're gonna need your help because yes
we are going to have a beta and we have
an awesome collector's edition for you
it starts with a map of the world that
glows in the [ __ ] dark
you're probably wondering when is this
game coming out we're excited to say
that it's coming out this year
November 14th fallout shelter is coming
to the PlayStation 4 and because that
guy said it it's also coming to the
Nintendo switch we have also been
working on a brand new next-generation
single-player game
starfield is a game that we have spent
years thinking about and working on
something we feel uniquely positioned to
pull off and that we're incredibly
excited about
[Music]
we're also building toward the game
after that and it's the one you keep
asking about
[Applause]
[Music]
I just want to thank you all for your
time tonight the time you've spent in
our worlds we'll see you out there
[Applause]
you